Some things are best kept contained.
After all, this is the founding principle
behind the SCP Foundation themselves, to secure
and contain the most dangerous anomalies in
order to protect human lives.
But within the Foundation itself, are things
which should never be uncovered, secrets that
must never be told.
Secured behind multiple layers of containment
like the Seven Seals of Revelation, is a threat
so high level in its nature that it can’t
even be given a class: SCP-5999.
But in order to truly understand this late
series SCP, we have to go all the way back
to one of the earliest.
Anyone looking for SCP-001 will quickly realize
that there are several different entities
and anomalies that share this designation.
Many reasons have been given for this classification
quirk.
Perhaps they were all discovered in the early
days of the Foundation, before the current
numbering system was introduced.
Others have suggested that the many different
SCP-001s are an intentional misdirection by
the Foundation, to keep the nature of the
true first SCP a closely-guarded secret.
One of the many entries, and the one we’ll
be referring to as SCP-001 to understand SCP-5999,
is otherwise known as ‘The Database’.
Information about The Database is kept a secret
to the entire SCP Foundation apart from the
Overseer Council.
The reason behind this?
Well, that would be because this SCP-001 contains
details of the very nature of the Foundation
itself, including its creation.
Not how the organization was founded, mind
you; how it was created, and by whom.
We’re about to break the most powerful layer
of containment of all: The fourth wall.
You see, to you or I, the SCP Foundation and
its vast catalogue of user generated articles
on the creative and the creepy are nothing
more than a source of entertainment.
It can be fun to study the lore and the nuances
of different SCPs, appreciating the imagination
and hard work that the authors put into writing
them.
It can even inspire us, fuel our own written
endeavors, whether that takes the form of
fan fiction, independent stories, original
SCPs or even a YouTube series.
But, when all is said and done, we all know
that the SCP Foundation is fictional.
And they know it too.
Pieced together from various fragments of
information within their own archives, The
Database contains everything the Foundation
knows about the real world authors of the
SCP Wiki.
Just like we told you, it’s time to wave
a fond farewell to the fourth wall, the metaphorical
barrier that separates what we know to be
real from what we know to be purely fiction.
The fact that they exist in this fictional
capacity is something the Overseer Council
hopes to hide from the rest of the Foundation’s
personnel, but they also have plans in mind
for the SCP Wiki writers responsible for creating
them and expanding the roster of anomalies
they keep contained.
The SCP Wiki entry on SCP-001 The Database
closes with a proposal, a plan from the O5
Council to reach the wiki’s authors in the
real world, through memetic kill agents that
will put them to sleep and then kill them.
With that important background context in
mind, now let’s go all the way back to the
other end of the SCP wiki and take a look
at SCP-5999.
When first accessing the file, you, the reader,
will notice a few format differences between
this entry and others within the SCP Archive.
Each section of SCP-5999 is hidden behind
an encryption, and accessing these will reveal
the different ‘levels’ of this entry.
Remember how we mentioned the Seven Seals
of Revelation at the start of this video?
That wasn’t a coincidence.
In the Bible’s Book of Revelation, there
are seven symbolic seals securing a book that
John of Patmos saw in his vision of the apocalypse.
When these seven seals are broken, and the
book is opened, this symbolizes the Second
Coming of the Messiah and marks the beginning
of the biblical apocalypse.
In much the same vein, SCP-5999 is sealed
in seven different parts, each behind its
own encryption, culminating in one apocalyptic
ending.
So, at this point you are probably thinking,
what actually is SCP-5999?
What could be so dangerous that it has to
stay hidden in multiple segments?
Well, on the surface, SCP-5999 is just a story.
It details one of the SCP Foundation’s many
investigations into an anomalous object.
Nothing too strange about that.
But there’s something more to it, since
with the Foundation there always is.
And it has something to do with the images
at the header of each section of the entry.
At the top of each part of SCP-5999 is a picture
of a group of candles, seven to be exact.
But the further down you read, one by one
the candles start to go out, until you reach
the end of SCP-5999.
Delving into the first of these sections,
the SCP-5999 entry describes a corpse that
seems to be cursed with multiple anomalous
properties.
After the assault and murder of one Ms Jacqueline
Holcroft, her remains were scattered.
According to the entry, any person coming
into contact with a part of Ms Holcroft’s
deceased body, or anyone who learns about
what caused her death, will experience anomalous
effects.
These manifest in various ways, for example,
subjects may hallucinate that they see a disheveled
woman with wounds similar to Ms Holcroft’s
before her dismemberment.
This sight is sometimes accompanied by sounds
of whispering and even begging that calls
the subject seeing and hearing things by their
name.
Others have reported hearing an unknown song
set to the tune of ‘Twinkle, Twinkle Little
Star’.
The anomalous influence of Ms Holcroft’s
dismembered remains is known to continue until
a subject’s death, with many reporting seeing
the woman’s deceased body lurking in their
old photos or suffering sleep paralysis as
they feel something being forcibly removed
from their guts.
Some subjects even report discovering body
parts and organs, anything from fingers to
eyes, to teeth and hair, and finding it at
random places such as when opening a drawer
or in their food.
Finally, a number of subjects affected by
the remains of Ms Holcroft have reported a
specific irrational fear, the fear that the
chains are weakening.
Even after the Foundation recovered Jacqueline
Holcroft’s bones and her remains were buried
in a proper funeral, the effects that her
dead body parts had over living subjects did
not stop.
Subjects reported their children went missing,
and the attendees at Ms Holcroft’s funeral
were somehow spontaneously disemboweled after
the ceremony.
To keep these effects to a minimum, the Foundation
apparently has a containment procedure in
place.
The SCP-5999 entry details something called
‘Procedure Sevenfold’, wherein the SCP
Foundation gathers seven civilians and brings
them to a location called Albright Manor.
On October 30th, these seven people are sedated
and awake on the night of October 31st.
All entrances to Albright Manor are sealed,
trapping the civilians inside.
Observed via a network of surveillance devices
throughout the Manor, Procedure Sevenfold
always results in the deaths of the seven
civilian witnesses brought in by the Foundation.
Whether they are told to perform a ritual,
or are offered as a sacrifice, is unclear.
The following morning, Foundation clean-up
crews will remove the remains of these people,
disposing of their bodies with an incinerator.
For the rest of the year, until Procedure
Sevenfold needs to be conducted again, Foundation
personnel on site at Albright Manor are instructed
to be careful around any surfaces that contain
the phrase “This is where I died.”
By now, you are most likely wondering what
the remains of Ms Holcroft and Procedure Sevenfold
have to do with anything we’ve talked about
so far.
What is the connection to SCP-001, The Database?
Is there something linking an anomalous corpse
with the Foundation’s knowledge of its own
fictional existence?
What does “a fear of the chains weakening”
mean?
And why do none of these questions seem to
acknowledge what those seven candles represent,
or why they’re still gradually going out?
Scrolling further through SCP-5999 doesn’t
seem to yield many more answers though.
In fact, the more of the sections you look
into, the less it seems to be about Ms Holcroft,
or even make any link to The Database.
And the deeper you go, the fewer candles remain
lit.
The next few portions of the SCP-5999 entry
are dedicated to completely different investigations
that have little to nothing to do with Procedure
Sevenfold.
Ms Holcroft’s corpse and the anomalous effects
it creates are also absent in the later segments
of this entry in the SCP Archive.
So, if the cursed body parts of Jacqueline
Holcroft are not SCP-5999, then what is?
One report details the fates of a Mobile Task
Force, trapped in a fog shrouded town.
Here, they encounter a lamb that appears to
be undead, and devolves into an ungodly winged
beast before the MTF team’s very eyes.
Another that follows, is a transcript of an
exorcism.
During a classified Foundation operation,
one Agent Grace was possessed by a demonic
entity, and sent to the Department of Demonology.
Specialist in Demonic Psychology Doctor Peter
MacNeill attempted to remove the demon inhabiting
Agent Grace.
However, after trying to intimidate the demonic
entity with various passages from biblical
texts, it appears as though maybe the demon
was able to spread its influence to both Agent
Grace and Doctor MacNeill.
Of course, neither of these reports seem to
answer any of the pressing questions, or explain
the exact nature of SCP-5999.
As you go further into the entry, you can’t
help but notice how often chains are referenced.
In fact, that seemed to be the one thing constant
in all these disjointed segments.
Mentions of a “failure of the chains to
hold what lies beneath”, and chains that
have become “too few in number to hold it”
all create the sense that something once was
locked up, sealed securely away, is managing
to break free.
Then, finally, as the last candle goes out,
you are literally brought face-to-face with
the horror of SCP-5999, and its true nature
is revealed to you.
A decaying, desiccated corpse stares out of
the screen at you.
Its eyes are sunken deep into its skull, lips
shriveled almost completely away, exposing
rows of rotten teeth.
Could it be Ms Holcroft’s body?
You aren’t sure.
What you are sure of, is the corpse’s face
is getting closer to the screen, and now…
it’s smiling at you.
You can feel your heart pounding, beating
against your ribcage.
As the world around you begins to fade, and
your life slips away from you, the last thing
you see is the grim face of the corpse staring
out at you with it’s dead, sunken eyes.
The truth of SCP-5999 is that it has been
specifically designed to kill whoever reads
it.
By whom, you may be asking?
By the SCP Foundation themselves.
Cast your mind back to The Database and remember
that the Overseer Council are aware of their
own fictional existence.
They know that they aren’t real, and plan
to use a memetic kill agent to take out the
SCP Wiki authors that created them.
SCP-5999 is that kill agent, an entity created
by fiction to kill those living in reality.
SCP-5999 works by drawing a person in, offering
disjointed and disconnected horror stories
as a means of grabbing a reader’s attention.
Further and further down through the entry
that person will go, searching for the meaning
behind these chilling tales.
And therein lies the trap.
Each layer, each section of SCP-5999 that
you read is another candle extinguished.
And with every flame that goes out, a seal
broken, a chain becomes unbound, allowing
the entity contained within the archive entry
itself to get closer.
Its sole purpose is to fulfil the proposal
laid out by the O5 Council after they learned
that they were fictional, along with the entire
SCP universe.
By pulling you in with the mystery and intrigue
of the confusing, convoluted stories, SCP-5999
is able to deploy, jumping out of the screen
towards you, condemning you to a dark and
grisly fate.
Or maybe that’s just what the O5 Council
and the SCP Foundation wants us to think.
Either way, it might just be safer to get
your SCP knowledge here at SCP Explained.
And speaking of…
Go check out “SCP-1730 - What Happened to
Site-13?
The Full Story Compilation” and “SCP-5545
- Mysterious Tunnels in Antarctica - ABNORMALITY”
for more terrifying tales.
But at least these ones won’t kill you.
Probably...